some of the earliest experiments with  electricity in the body relied on eels  and others strongly electric fish but  until now how eels use their electric  discharges to hunt and kill their prey  has not been understood you'd think that  eels kill by shocking their prep sending  out big waves of electricity swapping  the systems of the small fish and  invertebrates that they eat  in fact eels hunt and kill their prey in  a very precise way their shocks are  tuned to the same frequencies as the  nerves and muscle using one kind of  pulse eels can make their prey freeze  making them easy to catch as they float  helplessly by or a hunting eel can  release pulses that cause hidden prey to  twitch involuntarily revealing their  location then the eel can paralyze them  at a distance like a Taser one question  still remains though why don't you lose  shocks themselves  you